ومن جنديرس ينضم الينا مدير الدفاع المدني
البيضاء رائد الصالح اهلا بك اذا ناشدتم
طلبتم العون وانتم راس حربه الانقاذ في
الشمال السوري واخيرا جاءت رساله اقرب الى
الياس هل فعلا فقدتم الامل بالوصول الى
نجيل من تحت الانقاض
نعم فعليا تم يعني مع الاسف انه ما عاد اي
ليس هناك اي امل بايجاد اي ناجين من تحت
الانقاض ونحن نعمل على انتشار الجثث اعتقد
الى مسائل غد او خلال 48 الساعه القادمه
نكون انهينا كل عمليات البحث والانتشال
الجثث من تحت الانقاض وسنبدا نتحدث عن
جندي بالتحديد
جنديرس وحارم وسلقين معظم المناطق فعليا
انهينا العمل بها تبقى لدينا ثلاث مواقع
الان نعمل بها هي سلقين وحارم وجنديرس
باقي المواقع الاتاري بالدانا سرمدا
الجيني
دركوش الرماديه عزمارين ادلب ارمناز
كفرتخاخرين هذه المواقع جميعها انهينا
العمل بها وتبقى لدينا عده مواقع بسلقين
عده مواقع بحالهم وعده مواقع ما زالت تعمل
لدينا الان 15 فريق يعمل في جنديرس لدينا
سبعه فرق يعملون في سلقين ولدينا ايضا
حوالي تسع فرق يعملون في حارم ما زالوا
ولكن مع الاسف يعني نحن فقدنا الامل ان
نجد ناجين من تحت الانقاض الان يعني الان
تلقيت معلومات قبل ان ادخل الى المقابله
وبعدها يعني الان بد ستبدا عمليه انتشال
الجثث بشكل اسرع حتى يتم حتى نكون لدينا
القدره حقيقه على
التقييم المباني التي
تدربت جراء
الى تقييم المباني سيد رائد الصالح
فلتتفضل بالبقاء معي سنتابع سويا هذه
اللقطات لانقاذ ام واطفالها ثلاثه في جبله
في اللاذقيه قبل قليل
[تصفيق]
العثور على احد
الاشخاص وهو على قيد الحياه بعد كل هذه
الفتره
[تصفيق]
العثور على احد الاشخاص وهو على قيد
الحياه الف الحمد لله
[تصفيق]
الف الحمد لله
شو اسمه شو اسمه
شو اسمه يا شباب
زكريا ابراهيم زكريا
اخي فراس
حبيبي
شو اسمه يا شباب ابراهيم زكي
أنا أعود الى رائد الصالح مدير الدفاع
المدني الخوذه البيضاء من جنديرس الا تبعث
هذه الصور بالامل لك يعني من جبله
اللاذقيه هذه صور لشاب ابراهيم زكريا تم
الان انتشاله من تحت الانقاض وايضا قبل
قليل كانت هناك صور لشخص اخر
لا شك انه انا يعني سعيد جدا اني ارى
مازال الاشخاص يخرجون من تحت الانقاض في
جبلي واللاذقيه
وهذا وانطاكيا وغازي عنتاب ويعني نحن
رجال البحث والانقاذ الدفاع المدني بمعظم
الاوقات لا شيء يعطينا العمل لا شيء
يعطينا الامل اكثر من شخص يخرج من تحت
الانقاض على قيد الحياه
هذا الامل الذي دائما ما نتمسك به وهذا هو
الكنز الذي نبحث عنه اصلا تحت الانقاض
لذلك يعني ولكن نحن حقيقه يعني انا هناك
تاخر كان في الاستجابه في في جبلي في
اللاذقيه في حل كان هناك تاخر لذلك هناك
اشخاص يعني نحن كنا في مناطقنا لن اقول
اننا يعني اسرع ولكن نحن بسبب عمليات
القصف خلال عشر سنوات ماضيه نحن متاقلمون
على العمل ولدينا
يعني ديناميكيه اسرع في التعامل مع بعضنا
ومتناغم
يعني يبدو انه لم يتعرضوا
الف شخص اليس كذلك لا لا نحن الفريق مكون
من ثلاثه
يساعدونكم ايضا هناك عشرات المدنيين حقيقه
الذي ساعدونا ولكن كانوا تحت رقابه وعمل
فرق نحن فعليا فريق القوه البيضاء في
سوريا هو
3170 شخص تقريبا
باداريين بقياده العمليات بكل المسؤولين
هم يعني هناك حوالي منهم 350 امراه ايضا
يعني كان هناك فرق
للنساء هناك فرق للرجال كانت تعمل وتنقذ
وتعمل ولذلك نحن حقيقه كنا يعني منذ 17
ساعه نحن لم نستخرج اي شخص من تحت الانقاذ
وكل عمليات الاستخراج كانت عباره عن اشخاص
فقدوا حياتهم تحت الانقاض ونحن اعتقد نحن
الى الغد او خلال 48 ساعه القادمه سنعلن
عن انتهاء عمليات البحث والانتشار ايضا
وليس فقط الانقاذ يعني
الجثث الضحايا
وسنبدا في العمليه كما ذكرت انه سيكون
هناك بدات فعليا من اليوم عمليه التقييم
تقييم عن متضرره
نعم فريق المهندسين في الخوذ البيضاء ايضا
ينسق الان مع مجموعه كبيره من المتطوعين
كون انت تعلمين ان الشمال غرب سوريا لم
يدخله اي فريق لم تصله اي مساعدات لها
بالبحث والانقاذ لم تصل ايضا الخيام
للناجين وللاشخاص المتضررين منظمه الهجره
تقول الان ان المساعدات التي دخلت لشمال
سوريا شملت مصابيح واغطيه لا يوجد فيها
اغذيه وايضا نعلم انه لم تكن هناك خيام
هذا الامر دعيني اتحدث عن هذا الامر
الموضوع مساعدات في سوريا الى في سوريا
الامم المتحده يعني انا اسف يعني دائما ما
ينشرون معلومات مضلله السيده التي تحدثت
اثناء التقرير عن وصول المساعدات وعن
الاعاقه هي حقيقه تنشر معلومات مضلله ولا
تتكلم الحقيقه ايضا رئيس الصليب الاحمر هو
لا يتكلم الحقيقه هم لم يرسلوا مساعدات
الى الان الى لاستجابه للزلزال الى شمال
غرب سوريا هم يضللون المجتمع الدولي وهم
يضللون المواطنين ويضللون قنوات الاعلام
ايضا من ارسل مساعدات دعني اكون واضحا
وصريحا في هذا الامر من ارسل مساعدات الى
سوريا للاستجابه من الخيام والمواد مركز
الملك سلمان ادخل مساعدات اليوم قافله
مساعدات دخلت من معبر الحمام وهناك قافله
اخرى تنتظر الان في باب الهوى واعتقد
صباحا ستدخل قطر الخيريه والهلال الاحمر
القطري ايضا ادخلوا مساعدات اليوم المعبر
باب السلامه
مؤسسه البرزان الخيريه ايضا ادخلت
مزراعدات من باب السلامه ايضا هناك جمعيات
اهليه ارسلت مساعدات
وسوريين ارسلوا مساعدات اما الامم المتحده
ارسلت البارحه ست
قوافل ست سيارات اليوم ارسلت 14 سياره
ولكن جميعها هي مساعدات مجدوله قبل
الزلزال خصتها وحددت ان هذه المساعدات تخص
الزلزالوا الى الان وانا تحدثت اليوم مع
مسؤولين في الامم المتحده وقلت لهم كفاكم
تضليلا
للمدنيين وكفائده التضليلًا وكفاكم تصريحا
انكم ترسلون مساعده انتم ارسلتم مساعدات
للنظام صح ونحن لا لا نعارض هذا الامر
لاننا نحن نرى اهلنا في اللاذقيه واهلنا
في جبلي واهلنا في حلب هم بحاجه الى
المساعدات ولكن ايضا اهلنا في في ادلب
بحاجه المساعدات يجب ان تكونوا حياديين في
ارسال المساعدات السيد مثلا روبيرت رئيس
الصليب الاحمر لم يرسل مساعدات الى الى
الى شمال غرب سوريا وهو اذا ارسل يريد ان
يرسل عن طريق النظام السوري
عن طريق ان التواصل لجاريم بهذا الخصوص
قبل قليل مع قناه العربيه اشكرك جزيلا
الشكر
هو يضلل شكرا جزيلا كنت معنا من جنديرس
مدير الدفاع المدني